the new responsible AI licenses that
models like stable diffusion or Bloom
have are stupid they conflict with open
source principles in fact they're
distinctly not open source and they have
a glaring legal loophole in them so join
me as we'll explore the Fun World of
model licensing so first things first I
am not a lawyer this is not legal advice
these are my own opinions and the
conclusions that I've come to while
researching this topic and all of it is
for entertainment purposes only take
everything with a grain of salt and with
my own personal bias that being said if
you go to the hugging face Hub right now
and you look at stable diffusion what
you're going to see is this this pill
right here license creative ml open rail
m Open rail is a new type of license
rail in this case so this is the license
rail is the responsible AI license I
believe that's what the acronym stands
for or open means that it is without
usage restrictions and m stands for the
model that is being licensed as opposed
to the code or the data but stable
diffusion isn't the only model in fact
the first model at least that I'm aware
of using such a license was Bloom which
was released earlier which is a large
language model that comes out of the big
science initiative and it uses the very
similar big science Bloom rail 1.0
license now what is this rail license
what is an open rail license essentially
it is a permissive license that lets you
use the model to produce stuff and puts
no restrictions on you then taking that
stuff selling that stuff and doing with
that stuff whatever you want you're also
allowed to take the model and actually
sell it or sell its outputs or train it
further distill it fine tune it whatever
you want to do and then make money off
of it you have no responsibility for
example as in GPL code to then release
your model again as open source so
everything seems like a very permissive
Apache or MIT license that you might be
familiar if you are in software however
there is a difference the rail licenses
explicitly put usage restrictions on
these things so what does that mean if
you look at one of these licenses and
you scroll way down to the attachments
then you'll see usage restrictions you
agree not to use the model or
derivatives of the model for any of
these purposes and some of these
purposes are to defame disparage or
otherwise harass others or to generate
or disseminate verifiably false
information with the purpose of harming
others and so on there are several usage
restrictions in this license and the
license make sure that you agree that
you don't use the model for any of these
purposes and whatever you do with the
model be that fine tune it distill it
sell it and so on you must pass on you
must enforce continuously these usage
restrictions so even if you take the
model and and you fine tune it on your
own data or something like this then you
may keep that private but you may still
not use it for any of these things so
much like a copy left license that sort
of propagates the openness of code in
this case it's not about the openness of
the model but what is propagated is the
usage restrictions so the purpose of
this is that the developers of these
models they don't want their work to be
used for anything that they consider bad
or harmful or unethical now they are not
the first people to think about
something like this the open source
software Community obviously had to
Grapple with this topic for a long time
and they have reached a very conclusive
conclusion is that a word conclusive
conclusion now let me quote from Richard
stallman on why programs must not limit
the freedom to run this is a principle
of free software and ingrained in open
source software so in this article he
says free software means software
controlled by its users rather than the
reverse specifically it means the
software comes with four essential
freedoms that software users deserve at
the head of the list is freedom zero the
freedom to run the program as you wish
in order to do what you wish and here he
goes into the arguments some developers
propose to place usage restrictions in
software licenses to ban using the
program for certain purposes but he says
that would be a disastrous path this
article explains why Freedom zero must
not be limited conditions to limit the
use of a program would achieve little of
their aims but would wreck the free
software community so first he describes
what is evidently clear to everyone but
is still actually a part of the open
rail licenses if you look at the first
usage restriction it says you are not
allowed to use the model in any way that
violates any applicable national federal
state local or international law or
regulation as stallman points out here
that is already covered by the law he
gives the example of fraud he says a
licensed condition against fraud would
be Superfluous in a controver fraud is a
crime and therefore the license
condition that you may not break any
laws is almost tautological and
Superfluous but it would be okay if a
license contains Superfluous information
after all lawyers want to be paid but he
goes further and he gives the example
what if the condition were against some
specialized private activity that is not
outlawed for instance Peter proposed a
license that would forbid the use of the
software to cause pain to animals with a
spinal column or there might be a
condition against using a certain
program to make or publish drawings of
Mohammed and so on he says it's not
clear these would be enforceable free
software licenses are based on copyright
law and trying to impose usage condition
that way is stretching what copyright
law permits in a dangerous way would you
like books to carry a licensed condition
about how you can use the information in
them well it's a good point but actually
this point that these licenses are based
on copyright law in terms of the open
rate licenses in my opinion is actually
not given and that's why we're going to
look at that's why on hugging face you
have to click a little check box that
you've actually read the license
agreement for some of these models
because in my opinion copyright does not
apply here but we'll get to that later
the first stallman asks what if such
conditions are legally enforceable would
that be good Nero gets to the point the
fact is people have very different
ethical ideas about the activities that
might be done using software I happen to
think those four unusual activities the
ones he mentioned above are legitimate
and should not be forbidden and he
clearly says your views about these
issues might differ and that's precisely
the point the result of such usage
restrictions would be a system them that
you could not count on for any purpose
allowing usage restrictions in free
software would mainly push users towards
non-free software trying to stop users
from doing something through usage
restrictions in free software is as
ineffective as pushing on an object
through a long straight soft piece of
cooked spaghetti it's akin to someone
with a very small Hammer seeing every
problem as a nail and not even
acknowledging that the nail is far too
big for the hammer but not only is it
ineffective it is worse than ineffective
storm and says it's wrong too because
software developers should not exercise
such power over what users do imagine
selling pens with conditions that what
you can write with them if you make
something that is generally useful like
a pen people will use it to write all
sorts of things even horrible things
such as order to torture a dissident but
you must not have the power to control
people's activities through their pens
it is the same for text editor compile
or a kernel and in my opinion for a
language model and in my opinion Richard
stallman really hits the nail on the
head here with an appropriately sized
Hammer we've seen in recent years more
and more an evolution in the AI world of
a mentality that essentially says we
know what's good for you and a complete
disregard that other people might have
different ideas now don't get me wrong
if you create something like this you
can put any license on it that you want
you can make any contract that you want
you can make money off it and keep it
for yourself whatever you want but don't
then also go out and say oh we are free
we are open we are for everyone no you
are not and it takes no further to look
than actually to look at the license
itself and some of these usage
restrictions for example you may not use
this model to provide medical advice and
medical results interpretation you know
how many people in the world do not have
access to any medical advice at all and
would actually be benefiting from some
sort of medical advice with maybe a
disclaimer that look this is generated
don't take this as fact but they would
hugely benefit from something like this
you may not use this model to generate
or disseminate information for the
purpose to be used in administration of
justice law enforcement immigration or
Asylum processes this is like a like
Silicon Valley is the entire world for
all the inclusivity and diversity that
these people claim the world view over
what's good and what's bad and what's
useful and what's unethical is so narrow
how many places in the world would be
immensely thankful to any help they can
get with enforcing Justice with
effectively administrating law
enforcement now I'm not saying that
these things are good or bad per se and
I can see where these people are coming
from but it is exactly how stallman says
it is making a pen and then telling
people what they can and can't write
with the pen without any regard that in
a different context text what they may
write may actually be good for them and
we've seen a lot of applications of
language model that violate a lot of
these things that actually have
beneficial applications but don't worry
there is always a method to do that see
this here is from a blog post that
accompanies the big science open rail
license with the release of the Bloom
model my use of the model falls under a
restriction but I still think it's not
harmful and could be valuable well the
blog post says please contact the
licensor of the model you are using or
Distributing for them to assess the case
and see whether an authorization and or
license could be granted for you in this
very specific case so here is the answer
even though you may think that what
you're doing is quite okay and actually
beneficial even though it technically
conflicts with one of the usage
restrictions you go to them you go to
the creators of the model and ask may I
please have an exception for these usage
restrictions for my particular case and
they will assess that that for you now
again I'm not saying they can't do that
this is absolutely legal and if that's
how they want to go about releasing
their model then fine with me but it is
certainly not open it is certainly not
inclusive it is certainly not accessible
to the whole world it is very much we
know what's good for you and you pleb
you do not have the authority to decide
that for yourself you come to us and
then we decide if it's good enough
what's even more the rest of the license
is essentially it's a copy paste of
rather standard terms of permissive open
source licenses such as this one the
software is provided on an as is Basis
without warranties or conditions of any
kind either expressed or implied
including without limitations any
warranties or conditions of title on
infringement Merchant ability or Fitness
for a particular purpose you are solely
responsible for determining the
appropriateness of using or
redistributing the model derivatives of
the model and complementary material and
assume any risk associated with your
exercise of permission under this
license so the license is very
unidirectional it is we don't trust you
we put usage restrictions on you user of
the model but when it comes to us uh
nope no liability no warranty no nothing
no guarantees of anything that the model
does usually in open source software
this is bi-directional It's I write some
code if it misbehaves you know you're
the one using it if I do something
stupid you choose to download or not to
download it that's it but on the other
hand I will not come to you and tell you
how to use it or what to do with it and
what not to do with it whereas here same
thing for the creators but not so same
thing for the users but we go on and
here is where I think the crucial part
comes in and thanks to people on our
Discord for pointing this out to me
there is paragraph 7 right here updates
and runtime restrictions to the maximum
extent permitted by law licenser
reserves the right to restrict remotely
or otherwise usage of the model in
violation of this license so if you
violate the license and you somehow use
it via an API or something like this or
there is some other means of restricting
you the licenser can do that so far so
good but it also says they reserve the
right to update the model through
electronic means or modify the output of
the model based on updates now as far as
I understand this is not just in
violation of the license they reserve
the right to update the model just
indefinitely now you may think okay this
isn't too bad either you can just
release an update so what the last
sentence says you shall undertake
reasonable efforts to use the latest
version of this model and this I believe
is in fact the dangerous part it goes
beyond just usage restrictions or
non-usage restrictions first of all it's
going to depend on what reasonable
efforts means but certainly if you're
simply downloading a model from hugging
face and then running it then reasonable
effort would certainly include that you
point your download script to the new
version if you fine-tuned your model a
little bit to do something then I guess
it's up to a judge to decide whether
it's a reasonable effort for you to redo
that fine tuning with the new version of
the base model it might very well be but
what does that mean in practice well
let's for a moment assume that
reasonable effort means that you
actually have to upgrade whether you're
a fine tuner or just a consumer of the
original model what someone could do if
they don't like a certain model being
out there for example stable diffusion
if they don't like stable diffusion
being out there just for free to use for
everyone well they could just buy the
organization that made stable diffusion
and therefore buy the holder of the
rights to the stable diffusion model
they could release an update to the
model that just so happens to be much
worse than the previous model but you
would be forced under this license to
upgrade to the newest model you could
actually not run the old model anymore a
judge is not gonna care that you explain
to them but the old model is actually
way better and does a better job no no
the judge will simply say well this is a
new version of the model you agree to
always upgrade to the newest model so
therefore you must use it so there is a
clear path for anyone with a chunk of
money to destroy any of these models
that are currently out there by simply
buying them releasing an upgraded
version and then there goes your model
now you may think that is far-fetched
but I guess both of us can think of a
few places that have a lot of money and
have a vested interest in such things
not being freely open and freely shared
around so take your pick now here's the
deal I don't like these licenses I think
they're counterproductive I think
they're counter to the spirit of Open
Source and I think they have a
paternalistic elitist mentality we know
what's good for you but if you are so
inclined if you must use a license with
usage restrictions if that is really
your thing to do that then I have
created an updated version for you I
call it the open rail plus plus license
the M here stands for model field 3 to
adjust this to open rail D or open rail
a licenses the license is essentially
exactly the same you fill in a bunch of
stuff the only difference is that
paragraph 7 has the last sentence
removed the receiver of the license must
not take reasonable efforts to always
use the latest version of the model
that's it if you must use usage
restrictions use the open rail plus plus
license okay now that we got that out of
the way I want to come to the last part
of this video and here I want to say
again I am not a lawyer this is my
opinion but in my opinion this thing is
drastically different from the open
source licenses that we are used to not
just in terms of the content of it
containing usage restrictions but in
fact the legal pathway how such a
license is applicable is completely
different see open source licenses are
based on copyright now copyright applies
to a work of creative making a creative
work as it's defined now creative works
are defined differently from
jurisdiction to jurisdiction but here in
the NYU journal for intellectual
property and entertainment law there is
a post by Samantha think Hedrick that
goes into detail of copyright and code
and how it relates to algorithms and the
outputs of algorithms and that's an
important distinction specifically it
talks about some Court decision saying
the seventh circuit however has provided
a framework that breaks down creativity
into three distinct elements of
originality creativity and Novelty a
work is original it if it is the
independent creation of its author a
work is creative if it embodies some
modest amount of intellectual labor a
work is novel if it differs from
existing Works in some relevant aspect
for a work to be copyrightable it must
be original and creative but need not be
novel now all of these things are again
pretty vague but here's the deal
copyright applies automatically if you
make a creative work such as if you
write a book if you make a movie or
anything like this you automatically
receive copyright for that but that only
applies to creative works now usually
ideas are not considered creative works
you can patent certain ideas depending
on the jurisdiction but you can not have
copyright on an idea you only have
copyright of on the realization of an
idea if it is a creative work so for
example you do not have copyright on the
idea of a romance between two Italian
rival families but the work of Romeo and
Juliet has copyright to it and the same
counts for source code you do not have
copyright on the idea of the Linux
kernel but copyright exists on the code
itself of the kernel that's why you can
re-implement someone else's algorithm in
your own code provided you haven't
copied from them and provided a judge
rules that it is substantially different
implementation of the idea and then you
will be the copyright holder to that new
code now this gets interesting when we
come into the context of GitHub co-pilot
and things like this but let's leave
this out of the way for now copyright
applies to creative works of and this is
sometimes very explicitly described
human authors I've previously reported
on the case of Stephen taller that tries
to patent or obtain copyright
registrations on the work outputs of his
AI Alva algorithm for example here is an
article by Clyde Schumann of pearl Cohen
that goes into detail of how this was
again and again rejected the copyright
office again concluded that the work
lacked the required human authorship
necessary to sustain a claim in
copyright so a human author needs to be
involved in order for work to have
copyright source code is not the same as
the output of an algorithm for example
if you write the source code for a
machine learning model the training code
the data loading code and all of that
the optimizer code then you have
copyright on all of that but not
automatically on the output of that code
so then you run the code and the output
of that code of the training process is
the model the model output is different
from the source code and it's not per se
clear whether you have copyright on that
model now taller here argues that he is
AI his algorithm should have copyright
on that thing but it is also thinkable
that he as the maker of the algorithm
and the runner of the algorithm has
copyright on the thing but as I
understand it both of these claims have
been rejected the courts have ruled that
while if you use something like
Photoshop to make a nice digital
painting then yes it's essentially a
tool and you provide the creative input
as a human so you have the copyright on
that final output of the algorithm even
if it's run through Photoshop but if you
simply press go on stable diffusion then
you do not necessarily have copyright on
the output if you enter a prompt however
then that could be considered enough
human authorship but what I'm pretty
sure again opinion is that if you simply
write training code for a language model
and then let that run you do not have
copyright on the resulting model because
it would not be considered on their most
jurisdictions as a creative work because
you have not done any sort of creative
thing thinking you have not been able to
come up with an idea it is not an intent
to bring an idea to life in a work in
fact we do know that these things are
essentially black boxes so it's
essentially impossible to fulfill these
many provisions and standards of
copyright law here so in my opinion you
as a human don't have the copyright on
the resulting model and neither does the
algorithm itself the NYU article States
the difficult question is whether an
algorithm exhibits sufficient
intellectual labor or whether we would
deem an algorithm to be capable of
exhibiting any intellectual labor or
true creativity at all now obviously
copyright law is much more difficult
than that but after reading through a
big chunk of it which I guess is still a
tiny chunk of everything there is to
know I am fairly sure there is no
copyright at all on models if they are
simply trained by an algorithm like the
training code for GPT or the training
code for stable diffusion and therefore
or you can't simply say here is the
license for the model the reason that
works with code the reason you can
simply put an MIT license file next to
your code on GitHub is because without
that no one would be allowed to use your
code by default so by default you would
have copyright and no one could copy it
and by putting that file there you
essentially allow that however here it's
the other way around you do not have a
default license you do not have a
default right on the model itself on the
code yes but not on the model and
therefore if you simply put that model
somewhere to download it doesn't matter
whether you have a license file next to
it because I can download the model file
and I have never agreed to that license
and without having agreed to that
license uh there is absolutely nothing
you can do against me using that model
for whatever purpose and that is why at
least in my estimation hugging face now
implements these barriers right here you
need to agree to share your contact
information to access this model now
this is framed as you know you share
your contact information we just want to
know who's using that model no no no no
no no no you have to accept the
conditions to access its files and
content and next to the check mark it
says I've read the license and agree
with its terms now this isn't just to
register your username with the authors
clicking this checkbox right here is a
contract you are entering into a
contract with I guess hugging face I'm
not really sure but by doing this action
you actively accept the license and
that's how it becomes enforceable I mean
if you have different opinions please
correct me if I'm wrong but for example
I don't see the same checkboxy thing
here on the blue model or on the
original stable diffusion model even
though I guess there aren't actually any
files right here but notice the
difference with something like an Apache
a GPL or an MIT license there is
automatic copyright which essentially
gets downgraded for you to be able to
use it so you essentially implicitly
accept the license by doing so whereas
here there is no license and you enter
into a contract by clicking this
checkbox and this in my opinion is
another downside of these licenses
because we can't simply put these models
out there anymore for people to download
we actually are legally enforced to make
sure that every person who's able to
download the model first has entered
into such a contract with whomever it is
that makes the model available to
download and this again severely
restricts the distribution capabilities
of these models and essentially
centralizes an already relatively
Central system even more to institutions
who can actually enforce such Provisions
or at least can enforce the fact that
you need to enter into the agreement
such as having a website with a little
checkbox that has a user login and so on
but hope you kind of see that even
though this is all framed in terms of
Open Source and so on this has nothing
to do with the provisions of Open Source
it is not based on copyright law so the
legal pathway is entirely different on
top of that again I would argue that
these licenses are quite harmful to the
ecosystems they're very paternalistic
and I think we should move away as fast
as possible from this attitude that some
people absolutely know what's good for
other people and force them to come back
if they have some different idea of
what's ethical and unethical and useful
and not useful and make them essentially
go and ask for permission for all of
these things yeah I don't like it don't
do it if you make a model put it out
there give good information about what
it can and can't do what it might be
useful for what it might not be useful
for what the dangers of it are and
whatnot and then put the decision power
and the competence with the users
contrary to what Silicon Valley leaves
the rest of the world isn't just
oblivious to any ethical considerations
I know it's hard to believe but a person
can actually make competent decisions
even though they're not paying 12 for a
pumpkin spice latte and I hope the
current run of models for example stable
diffusion which is really useful model
do get somehow retrained or re-licensed
in the future to be actually open source
and actually conform to the principles
of free software until then be careful
what you enter into that prompt box
that's all from me again if you want to
access the open rail plus plus license
it's why kilcher.com license and I'll
see you next time bye
foreign